[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAX KIRCH: Quick
overview of just how
we think about fleet
management and what
it means to build a modern
scalable device management
solution.
Marcus is going to talk about
Chromebook applications.
And I think we have a
really unique applications
platform on Chromebooks
where we try
to bring the best of
a few different worlds
together from the web
obviously to Chrome extensions
and applications as
well as Android apps
and a few other
things that Marcus
is going to give a preview of.
And then Derek
will close this out
by talking about how
SoulCycle has grown
its business and its
technology together over time
and the lessons
learned along the way.
Like most sessions
here at Next, we
do have a Dory Q&A available.
So if you'd like to
ask any questions,
please just go into the app.
And you can tap on
our session and tap
on Dory Q&A. We'll take
some questions at the end.
And we have microphones here
as well for live questions.
All right.
So let's get started.
So one of the things
that we really believe in
is that organizations need cloud
native tools and endpoints.
And we think this
because we've talked
to many different organizations
of all shapes and sizes that
are rapidly moving to the cloud.
And so their employees'
experience now is really
centered on apps and devices.
We see a Forester study that
showed that employers are now
using on average 22 cloud
based apps and three devices.
So these are mission critical
tools for these employees
to do their jobs.
And we have a real opportunity
to make them better.
What we found though
as we've talked
to a lot of organizations is
that managing, and scaling,
and deploying these platforms
is actually quite tedious today.
And it doesn't
scale all that well.
And it's not because people are
making things over complicated.
And I think when we
dig into the processes
that organizations are using,
all of them make sense.
All of them have genuine
business reasons behind them.
And nobody is trying to cut
out any step of this process.
But I think the important part
is that it's not very easy
and it's not very scalable.
And we can do a lot better.
The other thing is it's
only getting harder.
Right.
So whereas at one point maybe
you were just taking a device,
and imaging it, and
making sure the operating
system and the software
was up to date,
and then you just send
it out into the field
and maybe you see
that device again
in a few months or a few years.
Now we're doing everything
through the cloud.
And so we're thinking about
not just devices and users,
but also applications, also
peripherals like printers,
network security, monitoring,
reporting, et cetera.
And so there are so many
new layers to the IT puzzle
now that we have to fit
together and fit together
in a way that feels
cohesive and that
presents an understandable
IT policy to our employees.
Now of course, we're
adding all of these layers
at the same time
that we're adding
just an unprecedented number
of devices into the mix.
So we're making it both more
complicated and scaling it
in a way that we
haven't seen before.
And so I think at Google we feel
that we have the opportunity
to help improve the situation
by focusing on reshaping
enterprise computing.
And the reason I say computing
is that on the Chrome OS team
we build the Chrome
operating system.
And when I say cloud
native, what I mean
is that the Chrome
operating system really
came out of the Chrome
browser project, which
is, of course, people's first
introduction to the cloud.
That's your viewport
into the cloud.
But if you expand the
Chrome browser and all
of its principles, like
simplicity, and speed,
and security, and you turn
that into an operating system,
all of a sudden
you have a device
that's not just
cloud ready, not just
cloud was added on top
of something existing,
but actually cloud
native, meaning
it was built for that purpose.
It was built with
the opportunity
to do OS updates in
a cloud native way,
for instance to do policies
in the cloud native way,
to do management in
the cloud native way
as well as applications.
So in addition to
the operating system,
the product that we have for
realizing this vision of cloud
native computing and
endpoints and tools
is the Google Admin console.
And so if you're using G Suite
or you're using Mobile Device
Management, this
is the same console
that you're already
accustomed to.
And this is where
you can go to manage
every single layer
that we talked about
in that previous slide.
And this is also where you
can go to manage your Chrome
devices and Chrome browsers.
And so when we talk
about Chrome enterprise,
that's the umbrella
product that encompasses
all of these different things.
We have fleet management.
We've got tools.
We've got the
application experiences.
And all of that
together is what allows
you to bring Chrome into your
enterprise in a cloud native
way.
So I'm going to talk real
quick about fleet management.
So I'll cover a few
principles that we've
learned over the
years from talking
to many different
organizations all shapes
and sizes, all industries,
verticals, et cetera.
The first is that fleet
management should be simple.
And so what I like
everybody to picture here
is put yourself in the seat
of an airplane cockpit.
And you're looking
around and you
see all of these hundreds or
thousands of different controls
and buttons and surfaces.
And imagine you don't
know what most of them do.
Right.
Would you look at
one and say, hm,
I wonder what that one does?
We hope that people don't
fly planes that way.
But of course, that's
how a lot of us
learn technology is we
just kind of experiment
and see what all
of these things do
but hopefully not so much
in an enterprise context
where these things can have real
consequences for our employees.
So I want to point out
the airplane analogy,
because I think
you also wouldn't
want to fly a plane that didn't
have those controls either.
So simplicity is not
about taking things away,
but it's about making sure
that you don't actually
need to be monitoring and
modifying each of those things
every time.
I think the realization
that we had was
that we can do things better.
We can raise the baseline
of what organizations
have as their baseline
level of security,
and policy, and management
just because there
are a lot of commonalities
across all types
of organizations.
And then you can spend the
time customizing things
to your exact needs.
Of course, simplicity is
also only getting harder.
So with a cloud
native device, we
can now add so
many more policies
than we've ever had before.
And so where as we started with
just a handful of policies,
we now have hundreds and
hundreds of different ones.
This includes things even
down to the level of hardware,
so things like two
factor authentication,
things like TPM
firmware updates,
things like processor threading.
And so I actually hope
that nobody in this crowd
has ever thought
about those things,
because they're probably
not core drivers to what
your organization does.
But at the same time
it's helpful to have
all of those things, have
all of those controls ready.
And that's the type of area
where we can make a big impact
by making it simple.
The other principle
that we've heard
is that device management
needs to be scalable.
So with respect to this
beautiful animating gear
here, that actually means
more than just the raw scale
of the number of
devices you have.
Of course, we're
familiar with all sorts
of scales of devices from just
a few to a few hundred thousand.
But scalability also means
adapting the fleet management
tool to your type
of organization.
So we work with
organizations that
have one admin who does things
part time every few Fridays
because that's what
the organization needs.
And we work with
organizations that
have multiple admins
with tiers of access,
different privileges
between them,
specialized knowledge in
devices or networks or security,
needs around auditing and
compliance and making sure
all those processes work well.
And those two organizations
don't necessarily
need the same
management experience.
In fact, they probably
need different management
experiences.
And so scalability is not
just about making sure
that it goes no matter
how many devices you have
but that it adapts to the actual
needs of your organization.
And lastly, our goal is
for device management
to be insightful.
So we really want to turn the
tables so that you're not just
thinking I want to
manage my devices
but actually my devices can
provide something back to me.
My devices can provide
some kind of information.
So imagine that you
have a device that
is checking in all the
time and then suddenly it
just falls off the map.
You know, was that because
that device got lost or stolen,
or maybe the employee
is on vacation.
Right.
It's not necessarily
a bad thing,
but it's something that might be
worth your time to investigate.
And so insightfulness
is about providing
that kind of
proactive information
so that you can pay attention
to the right things,
because even at the scale
of a few dozen devices,
it's just impossible
to keep track
all the time of every
single thing that's
happening in your organization.
So we need to have a
tool that will actually
work with you to help
make a lot of that easier.
So let's get down to the
brass tacks of the things
that we're actually working on.
The first one is
speedier administration.
Next is OS update controls.
We could probably
have a whole session
just on OS update controls.
We hear a lot from folks that
this is really important.
And it's also a big
opportunity where
having a cloud
native device allows
us to do a lot more things.
It's not just about
customizing the version
but it's also about how do you
scale, and deploy, and roll out
and apply updates.
Even OS rollback is something
that we've heard a lot about
and that we're working on now.
So OS update controls are
a big area of focus for us.
Reporting obviously
is something we
talked about with the
point about insightful.
And then browser
management is one I really
want to draw your attention to.
We just announced on Tuesday
the full availability
of Chrome browser
cloud management.
And so if you're using Chrome
browser in your organization,
which if I were a betting man
I would say you probably are,
this is a way for you to bring
Chrome browser into the cloud
and actually manage it
through the same admin
console where you're
managing all of your devices.
And so you can do things like
set policies, deploy apps
and extensions, manage
extensions by permission
if you want to, and even
get some information back
about what types of extensions
your users in your organization
are using.
So if you're not yet on
fully cloud native devices,
we understand that
that takes some time.
But browser management
is a great way
to get started today
with having some
of the magic of the
cloud management
in your organization.
So I'm going to go through
a couple of real quick demos
here.
One thing I want to
point out is that if you
are familiar with our
Google Admin console,
you'll notice that these
look a little bit different.
And that's because we're working
on a full visual refresh,
and adding a few new features,
and making it a lot faster.
So this stuff may
look a little bit new.
That's intentional.
And we have a number of trusted
tester and beta programs
if you're interested
in trying it out.
So for the first
quick demo, we're
going to do a device
search and disable.
So imagine that you have
a fictional organization
and we've got an
employee named Sandra.
And she's leaving
the organization.
So what we can do
is just go ahead
and search for Sandra's name.
And we're going to find all of
her devices in the device list.
She has 15 of them, so she
must have been productive.
We're going to just go
ahead and disable them.
And what you might
catch at the end
there is that we're
actually putting
a message on the
device itself that
says property of
organization, please return
to this address,
that kind of thing.
And so this is a
great example where
having a cloud native tool and
a cloud native device really
work together well, because
we have this just built
in to every single Chromebook
that you're managing.
And when you think about things
like information security
and data lockdown and whatnot,
this is a really, really easy
and integrated way to
do all of that stuff.
You don't need third
party software.
You don't need to
buy anything else.
It's just part of the
Chrome enterprise product.
Next is log capture.
So we understand
sometimes people
need to capture logs about
their devices for any reason.
And with Chrome Kiosk
devices, you can do just that.
So I'm going to go ahead
and capture logs here.
This is actually going
to run in the background.
So if you want to go to
somewhere else in the Admin
console and do another
thing while it's running,
you can do that.
Of course, once it's done, you
can go ahead and just download
the file.
So we'll give you a zip file
with a bunch of different logs
from the device.
We can open up the event
log in a text editor,
find anything we need.
And again, this is not the only
log capture system out there,
but it shows the power of
having things that are really
fully integrated, having a cloud
native device with the cloud
native management working
together really well.
The last thing I'll mention
about fleet management
is, again, that we are running
trusted tester programs
on these things all the time.
And so if you like anything
you're seeing so far,
or you'd like to try them out
and give us some feedback,
we'd love to have you do that.
Please just come see us
right outside the door
after this and we'll be happy
to take down your information
and get you set up with that.
I also want to mention if
you're using the Trusted Tester
program and you
send feedback to us,
and you're wondering
where that feedback goes,
it goes to my inbox.
So we are really truly
reading every single word
that you send us.
We care a lot about building a
tool that is actually simple,
and scalable, and insightful.
And we can only do
that with your help.
So thank you very much for that.
Next I'm going to
invite Marcus up
onto the stage to talk about
application management.
[APPLAUSE]
MARCUS KOHLER: So thanks, Max,
for that great first overview
of the admin console
and also thanks
for everybody in the
audience for having me,
especially after the big
event yesterday evening.
So I'm Marcus.
And I will give a short
overview of the Chrome OS app
ecosystem in the next minutes
and thereby especially focus
on the question, how can
we manage these apps.
Basically, the Chrome
OS app ecosystem
is driven by one core idea
that's very inherent to Google.
We want the open web to succeed.
So imagine a world where
basically all your apps
are on the Cloud.
So all the apps you are
using for your business
or your entertainment
are web apps.
In this world, you
could basically
walk everywhere,
use every device,
log into your favorite
web app, and you are done.
You could just be productive or
entertained wherever you like.
And with being
driven by this idea,
we have basically these
advanced technologies
of Chrome OS in the center
of our app ecosystem.
However, we are very aware
that basically, as of today,
it is not possible to realize
every application as a web
application, because not every
system capability is actually
a way to assert that capability.
So that's the reason why
we have these native apps
on the left side, namely
Chrome Apps and Android apps.
I'm sure some of you know
that Chrome Apps are already
deprecated on Windows and
Mac and that we invest more
and more basically into the
integration of Android apps
into the Chrome OS
operating system.
However, both of
these native apps
have the advantages
that you basically
can use all system capabilities
on the Chrome OS device.
And on the right side, you'll
see the Linux apps here.
So we are very aware
that not every developer
and not every user for Chrome
OS device will use Linux apps.
So basically, Linux
apps are [INAUDIBLE]
to support developers
on Chrome OS devices.
So to conclude
with Chrome OS, we
don't want to build
another gated ecosystem,
but we want the web to succeed.
And we do this by native apps,
advanced web technologies,
and Linux apps on all devices.
I want to walk through these
three pillars now step by step
and especially start with
the Android apps here.
So when I was at a
booth the last two days,
basically a lot of people
were coming and talking to me.
And they were surprised
that actually Android apps
are running on a
Chromebook OS device.
So yes, it's possible.
You can basically just go into
the place on a Chromebook OS
device and install nearly
every Android app you like.
There are some restrictions.
Some of them require a camera
at the back of your device.
So these ones don't work.
But nearly everything
works basically.
And if you look at basically
the app ecosystem that
enables this for you,
you can, for example,
use every communication
app you like.
So if you don't like
Hangouts for whatever reason,
you can, for example, use
Cisco Jabber on these devices.
You can use Cisco Webex.
You can use Skype basically
to connect to your colleagues.
You can also use, for example,
[INAUDIBLE] system close
and networking
apps like VPN apps
to log in basically into
the corporate network
of your company.
For example, one of
our colleagues at F5.
And you can also
use Read EI apps.
So for example, you can use
Citrix, VMWare, Microsoft, RDP.
All these apps
are basically part
of the Play Store as of today.
And with these VI
apps, you can use
for example applications that
are very computation intensive.
So if you want to,
for example, design
for these things on your device
like using a CATIA software,
it probably doesn't make sense
to carry this big notebook that
is needed to execute CATIA
all the time around with you.
You can just run this
in the cloud and stream
it via VDI to your device.
And actually, the
cooler thing is
that for all these Android
apps, they are coming out
of the Play Store.
That means that basically
the Play Store already
filters for harmful apps,
which helps to increase
the security of your device.
And as an admin, you can even go
one step further and whitelist
specific apps for your users.
So basically, you
prepare a set of apps
that your users should install.
And you can even
go one step further
and say, OK, I want to
install this and this app
by default for certain users.
So that's called force
installer in our admin console.
And this allows
basically the user
to use these apps
at the moment where
he logs in into his Chromebook.
These apps are
installed instantly.
And you can use them
just by default.
We'll see this later on.
OK.
But let's move to the core
of what is basically the web
apps here.
Can we do everything with
web apps as of today?
No.
If you walk around and you see
basically Gmail, Google Drive,
G Suite, you can
have the impression
that it's already possible.
But the true answer is actually
it's not possible as of today,
because some capabilities
are still missing.
And to basically close the
gap between today's web apps
and the native apps that we
have on the system as of today,
we have three clear
initiatives that
are described on this slide.
For example, we
have one initiative
that has the target
to basically provide
all APIs and capabilities
to support applications
in the web.
So this includes, for
example, system notifications.
Basically every app should
be possible to erase
system notifications.
Every app should be
able to create sockets
or an app should be able
to access the file system.
So we are adding these
capabilities step by step,
not only on Chrome OS but in
general with the Chrome browser
and a lot of
platforms out there.
The second step is that
you have progressive web
apps, especially desktop
progressive web apps, which
allow to install apps offline,
web apps offline on any device
that you like.
And your first step is that you
can basically use Web Assembly
to execute your C++ code,
which helps on the one hand
to migrate apps from
one platform to another,
but on the other hand
speeds up web [INAUDIBLE]..
So we have the
example of Figma here.
So Figma is quite a
nice app basically
to design Android apps.
And you can run it
completely in the browser.
It's using web
assembly based on C++.
If you want to know more about
these progressive web app
technologies, I
invite you to visit
a session later on today from
my colleague Thomas, ND203,
developing on Chrome.
And it's at 11:40.
And last but not least, we have
Linux running on Chrome OS.
So as I said, it's
targeted for developers.
We have Debian running data
where you can basically
execute your Linux
apps and they are
quite sandboxed from the other
apps on the Chrome OS device.
And [INAUDIBLE] has been set
up that we have running here
where we see a lot of tractions,
for example that you run
Android Studio on a
Chromebook OS device
and then you can basically test
the developed Android apps also
directly on this device.
And that's actually well used.
However, to be honest,
like the Linux integration
across [INAUDIBLE] is
still at an early stage
so it runs on nearly all of
the Intel based Chromebooks.
However, the Admin Console
Management here at the moment
is at a stage where it can
only turn it off or on.
So we are planning to add
these capabilities later
on this year.
To conclude the
app section, I want
to highlight that
basically all of the apps
are kept separated
via sandboxes.
So you know this probably very
well from your Chrome browser.
So if one tab crashes, not the
whole browsers crash but only
this tab is basically shut down.
And basically every tab is
isolated from the other tabs
in your browser.
The same holds true
for the web apps
for Chrome extensions for
Chrome Apps and Android
apps on your Chrome OS device.
Let's now move on basically
to the management.
And if you look at
management, we basically
have three main ways to
manage Chrome OS apps.
And let's start
with the first one.
This is basically you allow
the user to do what you like.
So basically you trust
the user to execute apps.
You don't influence it a lot.
And this setup is
probably preferable
if you have like administrators
in your user base
where you don't want to restrict
a lot because you feel OK.
They know what to do.
I grant them all positions.
Second way to manage apps is via
blacklisting and whitelisting
thing.
So blacklisting and
whitelisting works quite nicely
for web apps.
It works for Chrome apps,
extensions, and also
Android apps.
So the idea is that you
either exclude specific apps
from being installed
on the user's
devices or your whitelist
them so it basically
say, OK, the user has the right
to install this or that app.
And therefore you can basically
create a fairly good set
of apps and basically
restrict the user to what
he can do on this device.
And third step, I
already mentioned it,
is to force install
apps on the device.
So you can basically say this
app should run on the user's
device every time he logs in.
And you can combine these.
You can whitelist certain apps
and force install other apps.
And what's actually
pretty cool, and what
I like about the
Admin Console here
is that basically
the Admin Console
has quite smart defaults.
So for example, if
you are an enterprise
and you start the admin
console with its defaults,
you will see that
Android is activated
by default with all apps
available to the user.
So basically, if you
don't do anything,
users are in the
position to decide
which Android apps
they want to install,
which makes quite a
lot of sense if you
look at an enterprise user.
However, if you
are like a school,
so you have basically
an education license,
the default setting for schools
is that Android is first
shut down.
And even if you
activate it, it's
activated in a managed mode,
which means that you basically
whitelist the apps that are
available for these students.
And the reasoning behind
this is quite clear.
We don't want to play students
games during the lessons,
because nobody would listen
to the teacher any longer.
So basically, the Admin
Console helps you quite a lot
to have the right
defaults here and not
to do the wrong
thing by any chance.
OK.
Let's maybe have a
look at some examples
here that we brought
from the Admin Console.
So the first one is the
integrated app list.
So all the apps that you
have in Android on Chrome OS
are basically listed in
this integrated app list
so you have the Chrome Apps,
Chrome extensions, and Android
apps in this list.
And you can easily see what apps
are installed on your device.
And you can easily
search for them.
So we will see that we basically
filter first for all Android
apps and then we look
for a Google Drive
app in this example.
So we go into this list.
We click on Type,
click on Android,
and then we have the
Android list apps,
or if you just type
drive there, you
see basically the
drive apps that
are available for user base.
And the second example
actually is this one.
So here we basically
want to add a new Play
app on the user's devices.
And we don't want
to just add it.
We want to force it
solid and pin it.
Pinning means that
basically the icon
is shown at the lower
bar on the user's devices
so that he can easily access it.
And if you want to
do that basically,
you go to the same list.
You click on the plus
button down there
and you go to the
Play Store and then
you search for the Sheets
apps inside this Play store.
Click on it and click Select.
And from this time on, you
will have the Sheets app
in your app lists.
And now you can basically
select what you want to do it.
You can allow install
it but you can also
force install it, block it, pin
it, or force install and pin
it.
And that's what we do here.
All right.
This already concludes my part.
And now I want to hand
over to Derek who gives us
basically a true use case.
Yeah.
Explains his example and yeah.
It's quite very [INAUDIBLE].
DEREK MCWILLIAMS:
Thank you, [INAUDIBLE]..
Morning, everyone.
Good to see you all so bright
and early on a Thursday
morning.
Thanks Max, and Marcus,
and Google for having me
here today.
So like all the stuff that you
saw in the slides previous,
I'm really excited to talk to
you about how SoulCycle used
basically a lot of
technology that you
saw in transforming all of
our studios to Pixelbooks.
Want to give you a little
bit of history first.
So SoulCycle opened in 2006.
We had one studio, 30 bikes.
And in the 13 years
that we've been open,
we're now at 92 studios.
During times of
rapid growth, that
could mean 12 to 14
studios per year.
And super excited to say that
we'll be opening our first here
in London in I want to say June.
Each studio has seven to
eight classes per day.
And that makes about 600 rides.
I'll leave you guys
to do some napkin
math on what that looks like.
And then to make all that
work from the tech side,
we're looking at 2,500 staff
across the United States
and Canada and 500
computers across the fleet.
So when we started to look
at replacing our existing
technology for
new technology, we
came up with a few
rules and a challenge.
We wanted our new
technology to prepare
for innovation in the future.
So basically that means
for point of sale,
running transactions day to
day, for retail transactions,
and also whatever is in the
looking glass of technology.
We also wanted to be
able to allow our studio
staff to interact with
our riders in a new way.
So for any of you that have
ridden in a SoulCycle before,
we've got a front desk with
our studio staff behind it.
And we wanted to be able to
look at what technologies could
we use that we could
send our studio
staff into new
areas of our studio
and start to look at
different types of interaction
with our riders.
This is the interesting one.
What we wanted to do
was to try and find
a single tool that looks after
the management of our hardware,
of our applications,
our users without a lot
of like the
traditional glue that
comes with running an enterprise
suite of hardware and end
users.
Specifically, we want to look
at modern identity platform
security features like
two factor authentication.
We wanted to look at an easy way
for application administration
and also to tie that in
together with a single hardware
management platform.
And of course, we had a
good mix of aging computers
out there so we
decided how can we
replace that in a quick
and simple way that
doesn't end up with a mix
of hardware in our studios
over time.
Thankfully, we've
been PCI compliant
for several years now.
And in choosing our
hardware, we wanted
built to make sure that we could
maintain our PCI compliance
but also to see
if we could reduce
what that footprint would
look like over time.
As with any challenge
comes a couple of rules.
One, each studio
must be upgraded
within two to three hours.
We have a nice little gap in
between our morning classes
and our evening classes.
We wanted to make sure
that we could rip out
the old technology, get
new technology in there,
but more importantly prepare the
studio staff for that new tech
so that when the next
ride check in comes along
they already feel comfortable
with the operations
that they need.
They already feel
comfortable with what
a device may look
like both from logging
into the device,
using our software,
and primarily focusing on the
right interaction as opposed
to how do I use this thing.
This is probably the most
important part, making sure
that our studio staff feel good
about what they're about to do.
Changing technology can be
really, really intimidating
to people that don't
live with it every day.
This was one of the things
that I thought about the most.
OK.
Taking all of the challenge and
the rules into consideration,
we started to look around
at a mixture of tablets,
laptops, devices.
Do we look at replacing
our existing technology
with the best in
breed in that line?
We've been a Gmail customer
since I want to say 2006.
I wasn't there.
We decided that the
best move forward
was to leverage what our users
are already using with Gmail.
We decided to look
for Chrome Enterprise
and for deploying Pixelbooks
at all of our studios.
With Chrome Enterprise, as you
saw in the previous slides,
we're able to take a lot
of the organizational units
and the policies that
we could associate
with those organizational
units to identify applications
to associate applications
to those specific users
so we could tailor their
environment or their desktop
to precisely what they needed
to do to do their job the best.
With Pixelbooks, we decided
to go for Pixelbooks
because of, ultimately,
their form factor
and their aesthetic.
And for those who have
Pixelbooks right now,
they're pretty slick
looking devices.
And also you can use them
in laptop mode, tablet mode,
and I'll show an example
later of how we're using them
in all their different forms.
In moving to Chrome
Enterprise and for Pixelbooks
in all of our
studios, we decided
to also move a lot of our
traditional file servers
over to Google Drive
and Team Drive.
This meant that we
would be able to unify--
we'd be able to get some
of our enterprise users
that were on more
traditional devices
and increase the collaborative
function of productivity
of Google Sheets,
and Notes, and Docs,
and share that with
our studio staff.
For printing, this was
an interesting solve.
So we decided to go for--
we looked at some
hardware based devices
that basically use Google Cloud
Print, which was pretty good.
We ended up using a mixture
of Google Cloud Print devices,
Google hybrid printers,
but also there's
a Windows Cloud Connector that
we ran on our traditional print
service.
Thankfully, we were able to
maintain our PCI compliance.
Pretty stressful thing
to actually get done.
But what I wanted to
share with you is it's
a couple of things that
made that happen for us.
Trusted apps via the Play Store.
With trusted apps we're able to
essentially prove the integrity
of those applications.
With Google asset
management, auditors
like to know that you
know where your stuff is,
so a lot of the reporting tools
that we were able to use helped
in our compliance filing there.
G Suite IDP using two
factor authentication
as part of the user
security auditors also
really liked, and a
couple of other things.
So if any of you had to
deal with PCI compliance
before your internal
security scans
where they're footprinting
the devices themselves
and doing security
scans, very nice
note that there were not many
open ports on a Pixelbook
unlike a traditional computer
where there's usually
a myriad of open ports.
Once we put all
that together, we
sent our guys on a studio tour.
So we have a fairly
small lean team.
Broke them out into regions.
So we took California,
central, east coast.
We were able to send one
person to each studio
and easily go
through the upgrade
from our traditional
computer to Pixelbooks.
This is our Las Vegas studio.
I just want to walk you through
what you're seeing right here.
So this is our front
desk here where
we've got Pixelbooks that
we use for point of sale
and for booking.
And then you'll see
on the right hand
side this is a Pixelbooks
running in tablet mode
that we use for
digital signature
right of waiver application.
So when a rider enters the
studio, if they're brand new,
we can get them
checked in at the front
and then they can just
walk around the side
and then go sign a digital
waiver and go and ride.
But also because of the
way that Pixelbooks-- now
that we're looking at Pixelbooks
in different iterations,
we can send them out to
the front of the studio,
run retail, use them for
any kind of application
that we see fit.
There's a few things we
learned from all of this
that I wanted to share with you.
Listen to your users.
I think everybody when you're
looking at replacing new tech
or putting in new
tech, you think
you know what your users need.
We spent a lot of time
sitting with people
in our corporate office
and in our studios
asking them questions about what
their workflows looked like.
What are they doing
from day to day?
What problems do they have
with what they have right now?
And how do we go
about fixing those?
In finding those
holes, be creative.
I mean I've been in--
I've been working in
tech now for 20 years.
Sometimes there
is an expectation
on how to go about
doing something.
Right.
I need this application.
That does that.
I can fix this by doing that.
This is an opportunity,
or what I learned
was let's rethink it
again from, and looking
at some of the slides
from earlier on,
things like is there an Android
app that could actually solve
this problem a little better.
Do I look at reaching out?
Do I look at replacing this
app entirely with a web app?
All of those things.
And lastly, reach out to Google.
Talk to your reps.
I don't think that we would
have been anywhere near as
successful or have been as quick
as we could have been had we
not spoken to all of
our reps about how
do I make Team Drive
work with Pixelbooks.
How do I do this
thing with a policy
that makes that thing work?
I would have scratched
my head for an awful lot
longer had it not been
for the help of Google.
And I want to hand it back to
Max and Marcus for the Q&A.
Thank you so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]